entre cheverny et noël l'histoire
d'amour dure depuis près d'un siècle
nicholas c'est le nom du père noël en
allemagne où vit cette petite fille
ambre à 5 ans et demi et malgré la
surprise elle ne se laisse pas
impressionner par le personnage qu'elle
n'est pas fatigué avant tout le mois et
c'est pourquoi en fait le père des mois
il vient parce que noël en fête ses
adversaires de jésus et jets d'huile est
mort sauf qu'ils sont admis à faire sec
24 ils étaient 10 24 d'allemagne salé
depuis un an et demi et on a entendu ce
soir dans le réseau de familles à
toulouse on s'est dit on va faire une
petite étape au château de tintin un
très très beau château de la loire puis
plein d'histoires merveilleuses tintin
le secret de la licorne et du coup on a
l'occasion de découvrir est un teint est
également tout l'univers magique de noël
depuis 20 ans le château de cheverny
mise sur les décorations et les
animations pour attirer plus de
visiteurs pendant l'hiver le jour de
noël reste incontournable puisque c'est
le seul château du loir et cher à ouvrir
ses portes au public ce jour là il ya
une clientèle familiale qui avant ou
après le déjeuner a envie de faire
quelque chose d'avoir une activité avec
les enfants avec les grands parents afin
de réunir l'ensemble des générations
pour visiter un site culturel et comme
vous voyez c'est plutôt efficace
le château de cheverny a attiré cette
année près de cinq cent mille visiteurs
ces cinquante mille de plus que l'an
dernier
il gardera son atmosphère magique de
noël jusqu'au 14 janvier